hi my name is Elena Durazo I'm a senior
at Wakefield High School in Arlington
Virginia hello my name is Amit Bakshi
I'm a senior at Winston Churchill High
School in Potomac Maryland hi I'm Chris
suberin a senior at Fairfax High School
in Fairfax Virginia
hi I'm Carrie wax I'm a junior at Holton
I'm school in Bethesda Maryland and
hello again I'm John molesky and this is
close-up forum this week in our program
we're going to take a look at the
possible connection between pornography
and crime in the context of a new loop
piece of legislation that's making its
way through Capitol Hill in our
elections segment this week we're going
to take a look at the Perot factor
discuss Ross Perot's possible candidacy
and then as usual we'll have our third
segment where our students will decide
what they believe to be the most
underreported story of the week and
they'll report that to you and we'll get
to - in a couple minutes but we're going
to begin at the top let's discuss this
piece of legislation what I'm going to
do is read something from a USA Today
Wednesday April 15th just to make it
clear to all of us in to our viewers it
says that the bill would allow victims
of sexual assault to sue for damages
from publishers producers sellers
exhibitors and distributors of
pornography if the victims can prove
that the material was a substantial
cause of the crime furthermore some
supporters call it the Bundy bill after
serial killer Ted Bundy who blamed
pornography for his behavior scornful
opponents call it the porn made me do it
excuse Bill its official name is the
pornography Victims Compensation Act and
hearings on the bill have already been
held the Senate Judiciary Committee is
scheduled to consider proposed
amendments when it returns in from the
easter recess in April let's start with
a discussion on just your impressions of
this piece of legislation I'm assuming
y'all had a chance to read it
is that correct nice okay uh let's start
Alayna with you if you could tell us
what do you think of the legislation
well I'm kind of I think that the main
problem with the bill is that you can't
I don't think that the victims would
have any way to prove it because you
can't make a generalization saying that
everyone that reads porn is going to go
out and rape someone and I think it
would be impossible for them to improve
that they wouldn't have created the rape
even if they didn't watch porn so I I
think it's just lawyer lingo and they're
trying to get more money because I don't
think it would actually in reality be
very
successful other opinions who would like
to chime in Carrie can we go ahead on it
I'm sorry I think that the primary well
I believe it's it's well inspired the
fact that it's trying to quote-unquote
compensate for the victims is is great
balantine it's going to be achieving
that goal what will the victims
beginning if the victim can show I
believe the bill said that legislations
has a link between the the act of
violence let's say a rape and some
pornography then the victim can sue the
distributor now the link must be shown
and first of all if we can show these
links if victims can be compensated in
this way is it really going to stem the
incidence of rape I don't think so I
think first of all this this legislation
isn't going to do really anything for
victims it's not really going to stop
the crimes and in the end it's a waste
of Congress's time Chris your opinion on
the legislation as far as whether or not
the legislation is good or bad I would
get past the technical sides of whether
or not you can prove it's hurting people
or things of that nature I think it's
bad legislation because it is pushing
the blame from one person to another
it's going to push the blame from Ted
Bundy to one of the examples that's been
used is the Beatles could have been sued
for the song helter skelter after
Charlie Manson murdered the number of
victims that he did I think it's wrong
to totally go and blame someone else for
something that someone else did I think
there's also really two constitutional
questions the first is the First
Amendment I think this bill was designed
primarily to censor this type of action
Senator McConnell has been known for
this type of thing before and Senator
hatch another well-known person to be
willing to censor things is a co-sponsor
so that's one thing the other is I can
see a possible problem with the
Fourteenth Amendment and due process if
you're going after artists whose works
are being assailed okay Kerri Chris
raises the angle of censorship do you
believe the bill represents censorship
um I think to a certain degree it does I
think that if um the case if the
pornography and whatever
or form that is if it's a magazine or a
video or something like that if it is
brought to a case and and it's linked
and the case turns out where the pinara
free was part of the cause of the crime
then obviously it's going to be taken
off the shelves or whatever and then you
are infringing on their freedom of
speech and their freedom of expression
so I think that um but then again you
also have to it also depends on the case
you can't make a generality and say that
all pornography is going to cause
problems but some might you know I mean
it all depends even you can't you can't
stereotype each let's um maybe we need
to define a few things maybe we should
find out what your opinion is on what
what are we talking about when we talk
about pornography or preceding material
and I think the actual language of the
bill says obscene material when it comes
to pornography I believe that the
Supreme Court has said that pornography
is that which is determined by
individual communities and we're dealing
with pornography
some might say in some communities that
for example Playboy magazine could be
called pornography it's nationally
distributed however and if the
definition of pornography varies from
community to community
how can national organ 'national
publishers or distributor's be held
accountable for one community's judgment
of pornography as this bill this was
this legislation would have that
distributor accountable for anything no
matter where they are in the United so
are you so what are you saying carry
that out to the conclusion I'm saying
essentially if we can't really define
pornography we can't even find our own
morals we can't legislate them in this
manner
okay other opinions on just figuring out
what pornography is in the context of
this type of legislation I would agree
with on it that pornography is something
that's going to change from community to
community and that Senator McConnell
knew this when he had the bill drafted
and that further supports my thesis that
he's doing this to close down groups
that he don't he doesn't think are
proper so you're agreeing with people
who have called this a backdoor
censorship I believe that's absolutely
is there anyone who sees this as not
censorship the Privia proponents of the
bill say it's not censorship they say
that the things that are raised in the
bill are already illegal well I believe
it
we argue that it's not censorship I
believe it can be argued that it's
attempting to compensate for victims but
then my main problem with that argument
is that it's not really compensating for
victims
it's sort of an after-the-fact
retribution form of compensation which
first of all doesn't prevent the crime
and won't help deter any others because
there's no real link between the
violence of rape and an end and sex it's
it's perhaps a one of anecdotes but it's
not really statistically backed up I
think go ahead I think in addition that
we have to be very careful not to almost
have a repeat of book banning almost
like video banning because as Chris was
saying earlier it does not refer to find
there are obscenity is defined from
community community because you could
start banning videos that really
wouldn't weren't originally thought of
as porn but someone didn't like them so
it could almost create another book
banning where you're banning classic
books or classic videos because they
could somehow be twisted into some sort
of sexual fantasy that a rapist would
want to play out is there a connection
between violent crimes and pornographic
material sir obscene materials well I
don't really think that there is I mean
if if in if an if there's a case where
if there's like this repeated kind of
crime being committed and um every time
the crime is committed it's found that
the person who did commit the crime um
has been you know using the pornographic
material and then later on goes and
raped somebody or sexually torture
someone or whatever then that's
something and then they're not gonna
step further carry what if the
perpetrator of a crime
exactly copies something that he or she
saw in a video exact copycat crime well
I mean that then you have to say I mean
the poor net for the pornography is not
committing the rape or the crime the
person um him myself or herself is
committing the crime and you have to
differentiate between the two things
before you go ahead and um and start
convicting people of crimes right and
left you know I mean I'm not saying you
know if the trim' was being committed
numerous amounts of times
by me one person or different people and
it involved the same pornographic
material and the people were we're
committing the crimes in the same
similar way or whatever then that's one
thing but I mean if it's one person I
mean you have to you first you have to
get the scientific link that the
pornography is actually influencing
these people to you know act in the way
that they've been acting and in your
opinion I know it's a tough question to
answer you're not a psychologist or a
doctor but in your opinion do you think
this link exists I mean it depends you
know it means some people might have
that problem but you can't rule out any
other motive do you know anyone else
that chime in on this it's a time to
play doctor on TV do you uh I think the
important thing to consider the fact is
there are certain unstable individuals
in our society I think we can agree that
Charlie Manson or or even Bundy would be
unstable individuals their psychiatric
profiles would be riddled with anomalies
now these people whether or not they
have pornography in front of them are
likely to commit these kinds of crimes
and if it's if we can say that it are
they holding pornography because they
are initially unstable and they're
driven to look at this sort of material
or or is this pornography causing the
condition in them and I think in most of
the cases we see that it's not the
pornography that has driven this this
person to commit a crime but this person
is committing a crime and in the same
state of mind is looking at end up I
don't collect pornography okay I would
agree with that beyond that I'm not sure
I could really add anything except that
it's going to get into too many areas of
censorship as to what is pornography and
what isn't that's my main concern from
group to group also kind of to add to it
on it was saying you could even go
people could go so far to say to blame
the news for reporting the rapes and the
situation saying that that led them to
do it I mean I don't think that if any
one situation can lead a person to
commit a crime the person has to be
unstable enough to want to commit the
crime and they're going to do it anyway
if they don't get it through pornography
to get their ideas they could get it
from the news or watching kids play on
the play
or something else okay let's uh let's
approach this from another angle let's
take a look at the pornography question
let me well first let me do a quick
response I'm not hearing a lot of
support for this bill am i interpreting
your viewpoints correctly or yes well I
mean I don't agree with it completely
but if there was a case where it was
repeated enough to make it very obvious
that this pornography that's being
released is really causing a lot of
problems putting too many people on
danger in public then in to some degree
you probably should censor it because I
mean just like you know you're not gonna
let kids play in a Construction Yard and
that doesn't have a gate around it you
know our fence around it you're going to
protect them to a certain degree as much
as you can okay Kari gets us into this
new area I want to talk about how when
do you decide that something is not
acceptable but I think I think how this
bill um I mean pornography of that
nature that is going to be that bad that
is going to be so explicit that it is
already going to be illegal so if if you
see a pattern and you could prosecute it
under other ways like most pornography
well what I mean by it's already going
to be like well in fact even supporters
of this bill say that most of the
printer Agra fees that they would be
talking about that people would be able
to sue is already legal anyway so I
think it's starting to go almost over
and beyond but you have these areas like
child pornography that are illegal but
then there are other areas that are open
as a few of you have said already to
local interpretation what I mean those
things I mean in one of the articles
that I ran on this there was I don't
remember what the guy's name was but he
was a serial killer who was known as the
corridor killer or something like that
and he would watch xxx movies that were
on violent pornography I mean that I
would think I mean I'm not you know the
one that makes the laws or anything but
that's pretty I mean that's pretty
explicit that I mean that uh it couldn't
i mean supposedly sent him to UM do some
of the crimes that he did okay before we
end this segment i want to get each of
your opinion on this
of censorship if you'd call it that
limiting certain types of material I
don't want to characterize it in any
heavy-handed way I want to hear your
opinion but Chris let's start with you
where would you draw a line or would you
draw a line better question I wouldn't
draw a line and I think you can't really
censor certain materials at all because
before you know what movie is getting X
person to commit this crime in this way
you need to know who X person is and
then you'll find the tapes the movies
the books whatever in their home or
wherever but you're not going to unless
law enforcement officials or frequenting
adult bookstores to get this material
and research it before they can find out
what it's being done um well I agree
with the spirit of the of the
legislation if I if the Spirit is to
protect the victims because I believe
victims of these sorts of crimes should
be protected in some way I don't think
this is the way to do it because it
there's the problem of perhaps limiting
First Amendment the rights of the
individual and also because this sort of
bill is a waste of Congress's time when
we have serious concerns with the
economy where legislation can make a
serious difference and this sort of
legislation would rarely come in to come
into effect and if it did come into
effect would involve a lot of legal
litigation before we close this segment
Lena or Carrie anything you want to add
quick comment well I would I would agree
with on it I think that there's far more
important issues to handle and I think
even if the bill gets passed into the
legislation it's not going to it's not
going to help a rape victim because I
think it would be nearly impossible to
prove okay Gary any final word or leave
it there
well even believe it we'll move on to
our election segment each week we've
taken a look at the search for a new
president or perhaps the reelection of a
sitting president this week we're going
to take a look at the Ross Perot factor
and this is not a trick question
although you may think it is whose Ross
Perot let's put together a profile Carey
well this is what I know about him he's
the 1992 um one of he's running to get
on the general election ballot and he's
he's running as an independent and he's
given
he's committed four hundred thousand
dollars of his own money to his campaign
so far and he set up a phone bank that
receives I believe thirty thousand calls
a day or something like that
of people petitioning signing are
getting themselves on a petition so that
he can get enough people because he said
that he would run for the he would run
for president if he got if he knew that
enough people were supporting him and
I'm in that joining just then you keep
adding to the profile what has uh Kerry
left off about hospital well he's a
Texas billionaire in charge of a company
he's a very wealthy man and unlike other
independent or third party bids in the
past he could finance his campaign if it
became a candidacy past his opponents
and in a world where media means much
for the presidential candidate he could
make him give himself a a viable chance
and also he has a quite a level of
popularity which is unheard of him past
third-party candidacies Chris what would
you add to this royal profile of mr.
Perot well I know you also helped rescue
POWs and I believe Southeast Asia in
1969 with no permission from the federal
government or anything of that nature as
I understand it he also helped
Democratic governor mark white of Texas
several years ago in an education reform
of Texas which supposedly done a lot for
the state I don't know what has actually
happened but from what I understand
that's occurred we should also add I
think let me add something that uh he's
not an announced candidate at the time
this program now that here's the trick
part of the question you've told us who
he is did you know this about him before
he had you heard of Ross Perot before he
became a potential candidate for the
presidency I'd heard the name but that's
the level that's pretty much it so
there's all new information that you've
shared with us just with exception of
his business ties and his involvement
with the computer industry yeah I mean
you uh mentioned what you characterized
as a remarkable amount of popularity for
a third party candidate what about your
opinion of Ross Perot is he popular with
you well certain aspects of rosboroughs
personality are
with me for example his attitude towards
towards the making of decisions in other
words get the job done look at the
problem don't look at it too long what
make an informed judgment and carry out
inaction which is perhaps when the
problems with our with our country's
government today that the actions are
perhaps not as quick to come through the
system however the main problem I have
is that I would like a candidate on more
than personality and one of the problems
I've seen in Maspero is that he is very
reluctant to reveal his actual views and
his actual ideologies which I believe in
necessary to have a real campaign based
on issues um to add to that
I mean he's not running for he is not
running for president man he hasn't set
up a campaign he's just trying to get
onto the ballot so um I mean it's not he
doesn't really have to prove his views
yet until you know since that's what
you're saying right until he's actually
you know on the run on the ballot
running for president he doesn't really
have to and I think that um until he
knows that he's on it I mean it's not
there's I mean it might help him in the
in the in the end but right now it's not
necessary because he's not he hasn't
even announced it yet if he announces
does he have appeal to you as a
candidate yeah I like him I think that
um I think that he's really involved
with the people I think that he
understands that um there's more to a
presidency than charisma and being um
you know holding babies and for pictures
and trying to you know have personality
I think that once he's in there and if
he does prove to have good views on the
mean on the major issues that are going
on in um in politics now or whatever I
think that I mean he seems to me to be
really strong especially with the
economy with the economic views because
obviously he's done well with financial
on the financial aspect of his life as
he's a billionaire okay well like or
dislike mr. Pro as a candidate what do
you think I don't know if I'd say like
or dislike but I think he's very
interesting candidate being as rich as
he is he is able to commit the 100
dollarz he said he would to his campaign
and even without issues or having a
position on issues so far he's garnering
somewhere in between 23% I think could
you like to see him in the race I think
would make it more interesting yeah um
that's not an answer to the question
would you yes I would would you like to
see him president oh no I wouldn't like
to see him president but I would like to
see him in the race to maybe force the
other two candidates to come up with
better solutions I agree that with you
that we need to have more action but at
the same time I don't know as a
president if you would be able to deal
with Congress and some of their
loopholes that have to be followed
procedurally I think to a large extent
Ross Perot is kind of feeding off
everyone's unhappiness with both of the
major running kenneth's because a lot of
people I think are almost kind of
looking for a person that that they
really like or can cling on to and I
think that he was kind of feeding off
that but actually I think in reality
even if he gets on the ballot if he
can't be elected president I because I
don't think that he would be able to get
popularity and wide-enough areas to be
able to take actual states I think all
you could all he could really do was if
anything deadlocked the vote and make it
make it more difficult and possibly even
throw the race into the House of
Representatives which I personally would
think would be the worst thing to happen
okay Elena Bray's quite a few issues
let's stick with the one about your
segment he can't win that's what you
said right yeah anybody disagree with
Elena anyone think grass brokenwood
I just wanted to say that um he is he's
from Texas and um President Bush is home
state is Texas and he's been getting an
astronomical amount of support compared
to President Bush who I believe is in
the lead but still he's not far behind
him he's giving he's making Bush sweat a
little bit when when he's thinking about
how much support he's getting from Texas
and that alone would make would make me
think twice cos Texas again rustboro win
president why toss I mean it all depends
if he gets onto the ballot and he and
once let's say he's on the ballot I want
you to tell me if you think he can
people like his views and
yes very elusive today I want to well I
mean you can't I mean I can't like make
any predictions I mean I don't what you
want to make a prediction I would to
make a prediction I think a man like
Ross Perot
I think Ross Perot can win I think we've
seen in the past few months and weeks
throw the bums out mentality towards
towards politics in general and towards
Washington something the Perot is called
the bubble inside the beltway no I don't
necessarily agree with this view but
it's a view which is sweeping a lot of
America the fact that politicians are
perhaps corrupt or perhaps too involved
with the insider actions and the
intricacies of government and they have
lost touch with the American people this
sort of mentality may be widespread
enough to launch a man like Ross Perot
to the presidency I disagree I don't
think that I don't think he has a chance
to win I think that he has a chance to
get a lot of support but I don't think
it's enough support to throw him over
the top and I think he said you know I
think the main reason for that is that
he has entered the race too late in the
game people have already thrown their
support one way or another and he's not
gonna they're not you don't think they
changed their minds at this stage you
know the primary process isn't over yet
but you think people have made up their
mind not really because they they still
tend to go for the party candidates more
than an independent well you're saying
two different things there you're saying
he's not at a party candidate but he got
in the race too late which is it why
can't he win according to you I I think
it's both I think he's entered the race
too late but even if he had entered the
race earlier I still don't think he
would have won because people would have
tended to to vote along parties they
want to get a quick comment on the the
idea let's say he gets in the race he's
on the ballot and you have mr. Bush the
winner of the Democratic nomination and
mr. Perot who will be Hirsch and right
now of course people are talking like
mr. Clinton has it he doesn't have the
number of delegates delegates yet but
the math looks good for him who will be
hurt more by the Ross Perot line or well
Ross Perot win quick quick responses
because we have to move on I see with
Chris Clinton would be hurt more why
just because that's where right now Ross
Perot is bringing in most of his people
from but I would say that Ross Perot
does have a chance of winning the
presidency because with three people on
the race you only need 34 percent of the
popular vote to get
electoral votes okay carry a quick
response again who will be hurt more mr.
Bush sure mr. Clinton let's say it's mr.
Clinton at this stage well I think of
argument I mean so far as I know I
believe that it would be Perot because
if he gets enough support from Texas he
and then if he shows that he can get
that big state at my Flynn influence the
other smaller states to go along and
maybe um pay more attention to Perot and
go ahead and vote for him okay Elena a
quick response who gets hurt more the
Democrat the Republican actually I think
they're both gonna be hurt equally
because he's pulling from both parties
well there's something called spring
fever which I think may be operating
here the fact that at this time of year
this third-party candidacy seems to take
up steam and may lose steam by the time
to actual election comes but if Perot
does get on the ballot I think again
both sides will be hurt he will take
perhaps proportional margins from from
both the perhaps the more liberal
Republicans the more conservative
Democrats okay
time is short but we're going to try to
get through all of our students opinions
on our final segment each week we ask
our students to take a look at the
newspaper look at all the news that they
consume within the week tell us what
they feel was the most underreported
story of this past week and Carrie let's
begin with you what was the most
underreported story okay well I believe
that it was on the pro-life group called
up our operation rescue and they pretty
they made this big chaotic event occur
in Wichita and then against the
pro-choice people and so and they were
very successful and what they're
fighting for they moved on to Buffalo
and it proved that they were not as
strong they're the pro-choice people
held up their their place and they were
not able to get through as as
successfully as I did in Wichita and I
don't think that the news paid enough
attention to that okay Chris what would
you move to the front page oh there's
been several allegations that
businessmen and large corporations and
companies firms have been coerced to
give large contributions to the bush
re-election campaign in fact there
supposed to be a executive who was fired
because he didn't COFF up the money for
a fundraiser
for several times saying he supports
campaign finance reform and campaign
reform in general it's kind of odd that
this type of thing would be happening
under his name bobak I think I think of
a week or two ago a military transport
plane American was shot down in
international airspace by Peru and I
think in light of recent events in that
country a president or maybe dictator
Fujima Fujimoto's recent move to abolish
democracy to fight the drug war it seems
that this sort of action by the Peruvian
government would be highly suspect as
they are allowing a drug drug dealer
transports to move unmolested and I
believe that it should have gained more
attention and it may gain more attention
in the future hey Elena um mine was that
the DC government set up over the
weekend five school sites where poorer
people could bring their children to
have free immunization and they were
very disappointed because it was a very
low turnout that showed up and I'm
wondering why this is whether people are
just uninformed or if they didn't see
the importance of it that here is an
example of of people trying to pour out
and I was curious as to why it was such
a low turnout okay springtime is
approaching the end of this season of
programs of closed-form Elena are you a
junior or senior okay so this may be the
last time we see what are your plans
after graduation we only have a few
seconds so um I'm going to be attending
James Madison University yeah any
particular s course of study in mud I'm
double majoring in psychology and
elementary education homicide what about
you given with us for three years now
yeah third year last year for me next
year uh probably going to MIT
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
probably majoring in electrical
engineering but right now I'm not so
sure Chris a newcomer to the panel but
what about you're also senior yes and
where you headed somewhere in the
Washington DC metropolitan area majoring
in political science
my dream is hopefully an internship or
two on the hill and Kerry waxes a junior
may join us again next year is that
correct right okay that's all the time
we have this week Thanks thanks to you
for watching as well hope you'll join us
again next week for another edition of
close up for me bye